President Trump still blames Democrats
for this new administration immigration
strategy he tweeted last night the
Democrats should get together with their
Republican counterparts and work
something out on the border security and
safety lawmakers in both parties oppose
the current policy and are looking for
ways to change it Paula Reid is at the
White House Paula good morning good
morning the administration has
conflicting stories about its new policy
of separating families who cross the
border illegally last month
chief of staff John Kelly called the
policy a tough deterrent but late last
night the head of the Department of
Homeland Security denied there is any
such policy amid those protests over the
administration's new policy to separate
families that cross the border illegally
homeland security chief Kirsten Nielsen
is denying such a policy exists on
Sunday she tweeted we do not have a
policy of separating families at the
border period but last Friday the
Department of Homeland Security
confirmed 1995 children have been
separated from their parents between
April 19th and May 31st the Democrats
sought to disown it why don't they say
we're for open borders the White House
is now trying to shift the blame to
Democrats the Democrats forced that law
upon our nation I hate it I hate to see
separation of parents and children but
Democrats and members of the president's
own party say the policy is unamerican
it's to say that this is anything other
than just pure inhumanity at the highest
forms of the American government is just
law it is inconsistent with our American
values to separate these children from
their parents unless there's evidence of
abuse or another very good reason in
this morning's Washington Post former
first lady Laura Bush wrote our
government should not be in the business
of warehousing children in converted box
stores and current First Lady Melania
Trump issued a separate statement saying
she hates to see children separated from
their families we need to be a country
that follows all laws but also a country
that governs with heart but a
legislative fix may be difficult as some
of the president's core supporters
immigration hardliners don't want a
compromise former White House chief
strategist Steve Bannon if they have not
al
okay debt money for the wallet shut down
the government tomorrow President Trump
will huddle with House Republicans in a
rare meeting to clarify his support for
a new GOP bill that would extend
protections so so-called dreamers
initially the president said he wouldn't
sign it then he subsequently clarified
and said he would support it Alex
Paula thanks